Diese Performance-Projekte bezeichnen die Körper als ein Art evolutiver Architektur für Operation und Bewusstsein im Welt. In anderen Worten, hier haben wir die biologische Architektur des Vaters und wenn du Technologie dazu hinbekommen, kannst du die operativen Fähigkeiten verbreiten. Der Körper ist also nicht als ein Site für den Psycho oder für soziale Inskriptionen, sondern der Körper ist eher als eine Struktur gesehen. Nicht als ein Objekt des Wünschtes, sondern als ein Objekt für das Redesignieren.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 174 und mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch alle im Jahre 2011. Eine kleine Pause gegeben, Weihnachten, der Kongress, all das, das zieht immer so seine Opfer nach sich. Aber vor allem war es auch für mich mal wieder eine gute Pause, mal wieder ein bisschen darüber nachzudenken, wohin man denn eigentlich hinmarschieren möchte und wozu das alles gut ist. Das steht bei CRE nicht generell in Frage, aber man muss sich von Zeit zu Zeit auch mal wieder justieren und sich auch vor allem mal selber fragen, welche Themen man eigentlich mehr in den Fokus nehmen möchte und was vielleicht nicht ganz so wichtig ist, was gut funktioniert hat, was nicht so gut funktioniert hat. Und was auch immer hier ein Aspekt war und ist, ist eben auch das Zusammenspiel von Technik und Gesellschaft. Nicht ohne Grund ist der Untertitel dieser Sendung Technik, Kultur und Gesellschaft. Und deswegen habe ich mir jetzt zum Start auch mal ein Thema rausgesucht, zum Start dieses Jahres, was vielleicht diese ganzen drei Dinge ganz wunderbar zusammenbringt. Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Es soll gehen um Kunst und Technik oder auch Medienkunst, was da jetzt die richtige Bezeichnung wofür ist, das denke ich, könnte sich hier im Gespräch ergeben. Und ja, als Gast dazu habe ich geladen, Stephen Kovats, hallo.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, gerne. Ja, Stephen, wir kennen uns jetzt hier so eine Weile. Ich weiß nicht, seit wann bist du eigentlich in Berlin konkret?
Naja, die 90er Jahre und jetzt seit fünf Jahren etwa wieder.
Und zwischendurch warst du woanders?
New York und Rotterdam. You've traveled the world. Man lebt, man sich hier und da.
Okay. Und ganz konkret, der Anlass, dass du wieder nach Berlin gekommen ist, war die Transmediale, die ja seit einiger Zeit eine vergleichsweise etablierte Kunstkonferenz, ich weiß nicht, was die richtige Bezeichnung, was würdest du sagen?
Also man kann ruhig dieses Ding als Festival nennen. Das ist wirklich eigentlich das beste Bezeichnis. Das ist eine von den einfacheren Definitionen vielleicht.
Die es ja auch wirklich schon eine ganze Weile gibt. Da bist du jetzt der Leiter, Kurator, ich weiß nicht genau, was ist so die offizielle Bezeichnung eigentlich?
Na, es ist eine künstlerische Leiter. Die Citi mag gerne die künstlerische Leiter als Kurator benennen, aber das ist schon etwas anderes.
Kuratoren sind dann eigentlich die, die dann quasi im Team mithelfen, die Veranstaltung dann auch mit entsprechenden Werten zu bestücken.
Ja, die bauen das Programm und natürlich als künstlerische Leiter hat man auch kuratorischen Aufgaben, aber ich bezeichne mich selbst eigentlich in meinem alltäglichen Leben auch nicht als Kurator. Das ist auch eine bestimmte Berufsbezeichnung irgendwie, zu dem ich mich nicht so richtig hundertprozentig identifiziere.
Womit identifizierst du dich denn?
Na eher als Architekt.
Als Architekt, ist das so dein Ursprung?
Genau, das ist meine Ausbildung oder Bildung. Aber das Architektentum lässt viele unterschiedliche Sachen auf, unter denen man auch ganz ruhig sowas wie entweder Creative Director von bestimmten Sachen sein kann oder künstlerischer Leiter von einem Festival und solche Sachen.
Ich kenne so viele Architekten, die alle keine Architekten sind. Das scheint auch so ein Generalberuf zu sein, der so einen ganz breiten Einstieg in diese Gesellschaft ermöglicht.
Ja, ich meine, vielleicht musst du ein bisschen zwischen, ich weiß nicht, Gebäudeingenieur und Architekten unterscheiden. Ich meine, das ist auch wieder so ein bisschen so eine deutsche, vielleicht auch sehr europäische Sache, dass man wird auch nicht Architekt eigentlich hier oder in seltenem Fall, sondern man wird Ingenieur. Und ich habe Architektur studiert und ich bin auch Architekt sozusagen von Beruf und nicht Ingenieur.
Das heißt, du unterscheidest oder auch das Studium in anderen Ländern unterscheidet da anders, als das in Deutschland getan wird?
Zum Beispiel.
Und was ist man dann, wenn man Architekt und nicht Ingenieur ist? Kriegt man erlernt einen Blick für das große Ganze und die Fähigkeit der Durchsetzung im Kleinen?
Es ist natürlich verschieden, aber zumindest in Kanada, ich nehme an, das ist auch in Deutschland ähnlich, Architekten und Ingenieure arbeiten zusammen, wenn es geht um ein Gebäude zu bauen. Und die Ingenieure haben halt einfach ein anderes Grundwissen, ein anderes Ziel, ein anderes Vokabular an Methodologien und auch Verantwortung, die die Architekt nicht unbedingt hat und umgekehrt.
Wo hast du das studiert? Du kommst ursprünglich aus Kanada.
Genau.
Aus wo?
Aus Ottawa.
Aus Ottawa. Und da warst du dann eine Weile und bist dann aber irgendwann geflohen.
Ja, man könnte fast Fliehen sagen, obwohl damals hatte ich nicht so den Eindruck, dass ich davon geflohen bin, sondern eigentlich nach Deutschland gekommen, um in den ganz interessanten Momenten der Wiedervereinigung ein Projekt zu machen, die eine sehr...
Also genau 1990 bist du dann gekommen. Besseren Zeitpunkt hätte man sich ja kaum aussuchen können.
Und es ging um so ein Projekt zu machen für vielleicht neun oder zehn Monate. Aber da war ja halt einfach so viel los, dass aus diesen neun oder zehn Monate wurde zehn Jahre. Und dann fängt man halt an, unterschiedlichsten Dinge zu machen.
Zehn Jahre. Warum? Also ich meine, was hat dich dazu bewogen zu verlängern?
Na ja, wahrscheinlich, das war halt einfach der Situation, in dem diese transformierenden Land damals sich befand, in dem nicht fest es war. Vor allem ich habe in Dessau gearbeitet, also nicht in Berlin und vor allem nicht in Westberlin oder so.
Also im Bauhaus?
Also das war mit und über das Bauhaus, aber 1990 war das Bauhaus als Organisation, als Institution nicht gerade stark definiert. Also das gehörte zu dieser allgemeinen Undefinition in sich. Das Bauhaus existierte als Organisation in dessen jetzigen Form mehr oder weniger seit 86 und das hat sehr viele unterschiedliche Dinge durch die Wendezeit gemacht und ich war da drin mit, aber es war nicht so, dass ich bin zum Bauhaus gekommen, sondern ich bin zu dessen gekommen als Stadt, die in sich als Modell der Transformation, also als Beispiel der gesamte urbane, soziale, kulturelle Transformation diente. Wir wollten das als eine Art Labor benutzen und schon von sehr architektonischen und urbanistischen Sicht, aber dazu gehört auch die Medien, dazu gehört Kunst, wie man auch so elektronischen Medien nutzt, wahrnimmt, sendet und so weiter. Und da kommt man zu so einer Situation, man denkt von der Ferne, so aus Kanada, das ist ja alles organisiert und die Leute, die uns empfangen, also ich bin mit einem anderen Freund, einem anderen Architektkollege gegangen, ist alles ja organisiert und es gibt ja Geld auch, das Ding zu machen und so weiter. Und kommt man an und es ist schon so ein bisschen anders, denn in der Realität, wo man nicht so richtig weiß, wo es alles lang geht und gerade dann könnte man auch keine Aufenthaltserlaubnis oder Arbeitserlaubnis beantragen, als Kanadier in der ja noch DDR, noch nicht über wieder vereinten Deutschland.
Also du warst ja gar nicht in Deutschland, sondern sozusagen in der DDR noch, okay?
Ja, es war so ein komischer Zwischenmoment und natürlich, man hätte nach ein paar Monaten dann wieder weggehen, aber eigentlich letztendlich, als wir angekommen sind, das hat eine ganze Jahr gedauert und seit, bevor wir das Projekt, zu dem wir gekommen sind, überhaupt anzufangen wären.
Was war das dann für ein Projekt konkret?
Das Ding hieß damals das Experimental Studio Dessau North und befasste sich halt mit dieser ganz spezifischen Stadtteil von Dessau, Dessau Nord, weil es gab halt schon urbanistische Regenerationsprojekte, die um Dessau Nord gingen, direkt in der Wendezeit angefangen. Das ist ein sehr interessanter Teil von dieser Stadt, wo sehr viele unterschiedliche Strukturen zusammenkommen, also unterschiedliche soziale, aber auch urbanistische Strukturen. Und es ging darum, zuerst mit Studenten aus Osten-Westdeutschland, hauptsächlich Architekturstudenten, diese Stadtteile zu untersuchen, also mit denen zu beschäftigen, Sachen dafür und mit diesen Stadtteilen zu entwerfen, aber auch direkt mit den Substanzen auch zu bauen. Also nicht in einem Klassenzimmer zu arbeiten, sondern wirklich direkt in diesen Stadtteilen. Und das hätte so zwei- oder dreimal passieren sollen, also dreimonatige Art von Zusatzstudiums mit einigen Universitäten, so als Partner. Aber wie gesagt, das war ja alles sehr, sehr, sehr, ich will nicht sagen chaotisch, aber einfach unklar, was alles so ist, also auch von Behörden bis zum Bauhaus, bis zu einzelnen Personen, bis zu der Stadtteil in sich. Also das war einerseits ein bisschen so ein Free-for-all. Man könnte machen alles, was man wollte. Und gleichzeitig von administrativer, bürokratischer Staatsebene, passiert dir auch nichts. Und da war ja auch nicht das Geld, um sozusagen Leute einzuladen, wirklich was zu machen. Es hat so dieses Jahr einfach gedauert, um das Projekt in sich zu definieren. Und in diesem Jahr wurde das auch viel interdisziplinärer. Also als wir das dann letztendlich ausgeschrieben haben für den Teilnehmern, war das nicht mehr spezifisch für Architekten oder Urbanisten, und zwar auch nicht mehr für Deutschdeutsch, sondern international, weil die Thema, die Interesse und die Herausforderungen waren viel breiter und viel interessanter, als das in so einem kleinen Kreis zu belassen. Und so kam auch das Bauhaus mehr und mehr ins Spiel. Also es war schon so eine Art Projekt des Bauhauses, das Bauhaus hat auch kein Geld für so etwas. Und das jetzige Bauhaus-Kolleg, die es gibt, ist vielleicht so, man könnte fast sagen, so eine professionelle, akademischere Fassung von dieses Studio, die wir damals Anfang der 90er da gemacht haben.
Das heißt, du bist auf Deutschland gestoßen eigentlich so im Zeitpunkt des totalen Umbruchs, der totaler kaum sein könnte, insbesondere wenn man dann auch direkt im Osten ist und dann vielleicht auch noch nicht mal nach Berlin, sondern sozusagen auch noch mal so ein Ort, der wahrscheinlich auch erst mal ein paar Jahre brauchte, um sich überhaupt anzudocken. In Berlin ging ja immer alles sehr schnell. Ganz klar, andere Voraussetzungen. Das heißt, spielt dir das Wort Kunst zu dem Zeitpunkt eigentlich schon irgendeine Rolle in deinem Leben?
Relativ wenig. In gewisser Weise ja. Vor allem im Kontext von Kunstgeschichte. Und das sind Anknüpfungen zur Architektur. Aber nicht unbedingt so was wie, was man sagen würde, Medienkunst oder sowas wäre. Vielleicht zu dieser Problematik der Architektur oder des Architekturstudiums dazu kommt, ist, dass für mich waren diese Sachen schon miteinander sehr stark verwoben. Also sowas wie eine medialisiert oder Medienraum in sich und wie man damit wahrnehmungsmäßig auch auseinandersetzt. Bis hin zu der tatsächliche Struktur oder Bauen von so Räumen für das Leben. Also das waren so Sachen, die für mich sehr intim miteinander geknüpft waren. Und da gibt es sozusagen bestimmte soziale und politische Prozesse, die diese zwei Dinge miteinander verbinden. Und sowas, was mich dann auch interessiert hat und fasziniert hat in diesem Transformationsprozess, war auch der gewisse kulturelle, vielleicht abstraktere Auseinandersetzung in künstlerische Wege, mit so einem undefinierten Transformationsprozess umzugehen. Ich bin nicht in das Projekt reingekommen, von zum Beispiel der Sicht der Ingenieur oder des Baumeisters. Es ging nicht darum, neue Häuser in Dessau Nord zu bauen, aus meiner Perspektive, sondern es ging darum, den Kontext wahrzunehmen und daraus neue Bilder der Möglichkeiten zu erdenken, eventuell auch zu entwerfen. Wie versteht man sozusagen, dass das Welt anders ist, wenn das Welt komplett auf den Kopf gestellt worden ist? Das war eine von den Dingen, die mich interessiert haben. Wenn alles komplett anders ist, wie geht es dir damit um? Das ist natürlich auch personenbasiert, aber natürlich auch auf Gesellschaft.
Ist das deine Kurzdefinition von Kunst, dass man alles auf den Kopf stellt und schaut, was dann passiert?
Das könnte bestimmt damit zu tun haben. Das ist auf jeden Fall wichtig innerhalb dieses russischen Begriff von Ostranenia, die ich dann gleich als Titel genommen habe für das erste Video-Festival, das ich in Dessau im Bauhaus gemacht habe.
Ostranenia.
Genau, also das hat diese schöne Wort Ost da drin, aber das ist ein Begriff der russischen Formalisten Viktor Schlofsky aus 1916 und das bedeutete im Kontext der Literaturwissenschaft, das ist ein bisschen so wie ein Verfremdungsbegriff, aber Verfremdung ist nicht das richtige Wort, sondern das hat damit zu tun, wie der Kunst als Prozess unsere Wahrnehmung oder Verstand der Welt zerrt oder verändert. Es ist sehr prozessbasiert und wie der Kunst auch Zeit auch entzerrt, so man sozusagen die Sachen in einer anderen Art und Weise verstehen kann. Und der Tatsache, dass ich bin ja fast sozusagen so reingefallen als Kanadier in diese komische Situation in Ostdeutschland zusammen mit meinem Kollege Ian Johnston, mit dem ich auch studiert habe. Wir waren in Dessau selten mit unseren Namen benannt, sondern sozusagen die Kanadier. Wir waren weder Ossis noch Wessis und wir waren schon dadurch auch sehr irgendwie sensibilisiert zu dieser Problematik zwischen Ost und West und sozusagen aus Westen kommend war das, was im Osten passiert ist, schon sehr interessant, sehr faszinierend. Aber natürlich für die Leute, die aus dem Osten, sogenannten Osten waren, war natürlich alles, alles komplett anders, egal ob man für den System war oder gegen System, es war völlig egal. Also die Tatsache, alles, alles war ganz anders und in Westen, weil das war halt nur so eine Art Minor Inconvenience, könnte man sagen. Und diese unglaubliche Szenario zwischen Minor Inconvenience und kompletter 100%ige Umkehrung von Lebensumstände ist auch eine Art Materie, mit dem wir damals gearbeitet haben.
Also sozusagen du siehst so diese Entfremdung, der sich alle Leute im Osten durch die Umstände des Umbruchs einfach automatisch ausgesetzt sahen, ist quasi der Idealzustand, den der Künstler herstellen kann, indem er sein Publikum so verwirrt oder so in andere Situationen bringt, dass eben der Blick auf das Normale überhaupt erst wieder frei wird und man anfängt darüber nachzudenken, was man sonst immer als gegeben ansieht.
Also es bietet auf jeden Fall viel Stoff, aber nicht unbedingt in der Sinn, dass man muss das aufnehmen und sagen, okay, hier die Transformation in sich ist Materie, nur weil es gibt halt diese Zustand der Umkehrung und so weiter. Aber es bietet halt einen Kontext, in dem es war sehr interessant, bestimmte Prozesse zu beobachten waren und es war sehr interessant und notwendig auch, mit dann gewisse abstrahierenden Gedanken da reinzugehen, um sozusagen Dinge zu brechen. Weil es war auch nicht klar, was morgen kommt. Es war nicht klar, warum werden Wohnungen damals im Osten nur Mauve gestrichen? Warum musst du den Ost-Klo mit dem West-Klo ausgetauscht werden, weil die genau dasselbe sind und vielleicht sogar von den selben Fabriken kommen? Und da war schon in sich fast so eine Art dadaistischen Gesellschaftsgedanken drin, ohne dass man das wirklich wusste. Und das führte dazu, dass innerhalb dieses Projektes, diese Seminars, wir hatten Teilnehmer, die zum Teil aus Russland gekommen sind, zum Teil aus den USA. Und das in 1991 war noch relativ ungewöhnlich.
Vor allem an dem Ort.
Vor allem an dem Ort, genau. Und es gab einen Tag so ein bisschen so ein Auseinandersetzungen zwischen zwei von den Teilnehmerinnen, einer aus Russland, einer aus Kanada, wo die halt über Fernsehkultur geredet haben. Und diese bestimmte Codes, die man kennt als Kind aus Fernsehen, also Sesame Street, Sesamstraße und solche Sachen, Sitcoms, die man in Nordamerika kennt. Und jeder guckt dasselbe Ding. Man kann so Begriffe aus diverser Serie nehmen. Das ist Teil der kulturelle Code. Und in Russland natürlich ganz anders. Wo der eine ist eine sehr politisierten Art von Code. So haben wir das verstanden, aus Krasnoyarsk ist Fernsehen etwas ganz anderes als Fernsehen in Toronto oder so. Und da ist die Frage aufgetaucht, ist das Fernsehen in sich so ein politisierendes Medium? Muss das so genutzt werden? Oder ist das reine Entertainment? Also wozu dient der Charakter von dieser Sache? Und wir dachten, wir werden halt 12, 10, 12 Filmemacher aus Ost- und Mitteleuropa einzuladen, um über deren Erfahrungen, über diese Wendezeiten zu sprechen. Also 88 bis 91, so diese Periode. Also wie in deren Arbeit die Art, wie die zum Beispiel Bild aufnehmen, warum die bestimmte Bilder aufnehmen, geendet haben, oder überhaupt, ob die geendet haben, um diese Vokabulaire so ein bisschen so aufzuspüren. Und diese Gedanken, dieses kleine Seminar mit den 10, 12 Filmemachers aus Ost- und Mitteleuropa hat sich sehr, sehr, sehr schnell explodiert im Prinzip zu einer großen Festival. Und das ist dann, wo wir sehr schnell und ich auch sehr schnell und vielmehr mit der Kunst, was in dem Kontext, in dem Moment, Medienkunst auch bekannt war, benannt war, mit dem ich so auseinandergesetzt habe. Und da ging es dann darum, in alle möglichen Formen der Auseinandersetzung mit elektronischen Medien, zu sehen, wie dieser Prozess des Wandels im künstlerischen Kontext benutzt worden ist. In diesem sozialen, kulturellen und politischen Umbruch. Was spielte auch so eine Rolle von Kunst da drin? War das eine Selbstverständlichkeit? Gab es eine neue Art von kritischer Vokabular, die daraus entstanden ist? War das so, dass die Künstler, die mit elektronischen Medien oft in den Untergrund gearbeitet haben in den 80er-Jahren, die auf den Surface gekommen sind und da offen gearbeitet haben, führt es dazu, dass die Filmemachers dann selber eher in den Untergrund gegangen sind? Gab es sozusagen so eine Umkehrung, solche Sachen? Es waren die Fragen, die da aufgetauchten. Das war Grundlage für diese erste Ostraninie-Festivals.
So hat der das dann genannt?
So haben wir das genannt. Das war der Titel des Festivals.
Läuft das noch? Gibt es das noch in irgendeiner Form?
Nein, das habe ich auch beendet in 1999. Weil ich nicht eine Festivalgedanke über diese Situation in die Perpetuität fortsetzen wollte. Der Sinn dahinter war sehr, mit diesem Transformationsprozess in Ost- und Mitteleuropa umzugehen. Nach zehn Jahren wollte ich nicht dieses Ost-West-Ding mehr drücken. Obwohl das nicht wirklich der Sinn der Sache ist. Trotzdem fängt das irgendwann an zu sein, das ist ja Ost und das ist West. Wie definiert man Ost und West? Ich wollte überhaupt nicht Ost und West definieren, sondern eigentlich umgekehrt. Ich wollte zumindest am Anfang bei dem Ersten Festival eine große internationale Plattform, vor allem in Westen oder im westlichen Kontext, geben für eine große Bandbreite von Künstlern, die man nicht kennt. Und sozusagen Europa mehr oder weniger zusammenbringen. Statt sozusagen das zu sagen, das ist Ostkunst und das ist Westkunst.
Um vielleicht deine persönliche Geschichte noch mal kurz zum Abschluss zu bringen. Das war jetzt sozusagen eine sehr wichtige, sehr prägende Zeit, bisher gekommen, bis auf diesen wilden Osten gestoßen. Das ganze Projekt hat sich quasi selbst transformiert. Hatte irgendwie mal irgendein Ziel, von dem wahrscheinlich am Ende wenig übrig geblieben ist. Aber es ist dann was Neues entstanden, eben in Form dieses Festivals, was sich dann eben auch genau mit dieser Disruption selbst auseinandergesetzt hat und dabei auch sehr international war. Ich denke mal, das dürfte dann auch so ein bisschen die Grundlage für deine Berufung hier für die Transmediale gelegt haben. Dann waltest du wieder nach Kanada, beziehungsweise was hattest du, nach New York und Rotterdam gegangen und dann eben jetzt wieder zurück nach Berlin. Da hast du ja schon recht viel Zeit hier verbracht. Jetzt vielleicht noch mal kurz zur Transmediale. Auch die Transmediale ist ja durch allerlei Verwandlungen gegangen. Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, ist das mal als Video-Fest gestartet. Parallel eben oder explizit angedockt an die Berlinale. Genau, die erste. War noch sehr klein am Anfang und hat sich vor allem eben mit diesem visuellen, eben diesem Filme machen oder mit diesem, damals ja noch relativ neu, im Sinne von neu das erste Mal. Kameras wurden billiger, selber Filme machen war möglich. Und diese neu aufflammende Filmkunst oder Videokunst, die sich daraus, also explizit sozusagen Videokunst, als Gegensatz zur Filmkunst, das war dann sozusagen die Idee, dieses Festival zu starten. Wie kam es, dass sich das dann zu einer Transmediale entwickelt hat? Was, es steckt in dem Namen Transmediale drin, was in dem Ursprung noch nicht angelegt war?
Also das ist richtig, das allererste transmediale Ding war dieses Offshoot der Berlinale. Das war sogar der 18. Forum der jungen internationalen Filmes oder so in 88. Und es kann sein, dass die Zeitzeugen das anders benennen, aber wenn man das von außen betrachtet, das sieht ein bisschen so wie der Forum für den Misfits. Also, die Künstler, die Video-Machers, die Filme-Machers, die nicht so in diese formellere Struktur der Berlinale reinpassen, aber für den mussten wir auch irgendwas machen.
Die ohne Zelluloid.
Ja, aber da war auch Film dabei. Aber klar, es ging halt um ein anderes Verständnis von, ja, den diversen Medien, mit denen da mehr und mehr gearbeitet wird. Und ich nehme an, das war eine sehr West-Berliner-Geschichte, die dann natürlich sehr stark von der Wende und die Wiedervereinigung dann auch in sich aufgenommen hat. Wo dann vielleicht ein bisschen wie Australien, die wir zur selben Zeit in Dessau gemacht haben, wo diese Problematik der sozialen und politischen Transformationsprozess natürlich in den Medien, in den Künsten auch sehr stark wieder gespiegelt hat. Und wo halt die Rolle von Technologie in diese ganzen Gefüge dann auch wichtiger wurde. Das hat diese Verbindung Kultur, Gesellschaft, Technologie, die vielleicht aus diese quasi alternative Videosachen hat sich herauskristallisiert aus dem Kontext. Und wenn man damit anfängt zu arbeiten, dann kommt dann die Auseinandersetzung mit Computern, das anfängenden World Wide Web auch als künstlerische Momente und Orte, wo natürlich diese sehr, sehr enge Definition von Video oder Videokunst nicht mehr gegeben war. Und das wurde eine Transmediale Pursuit, so dass 1997 erst, also neun Jahre nach dem ersten Video fast, hieß das Ding Transmedia Festival und am nächsten Jahr, 1998, würde das die Transmediale als Festival.
Und das ist es jetzt auch immer noch.
Und so heißt das immer noch.
Wir befinden uns jetzt in der Woche vor der nächsten und deiner voraussichtlich letzten Transmediale, also letzte als Leiter zumindest, dann hast du drei Transmediale? Vier gemacht. Wenn man jetzt auch mal, ich will jetzt nicht nur über die Transmediale reden, aber sicherlich kann man daran auch einiges festmachen. Man hat ja dann als Leiter natürlich eine Menge zu tun mit Künstlern, mit Projekten. Man muss sich darüber Gedanken machen, auch was man überhaupt aussagen will. Und ich denke, das ist ja immer so ein generelles Problem bei Kunst. Und da ist es bei der Medienkunst nicht sehr viel anders. Ich habe immer so den Eindruck gehabt, dass dir auch sehr viel daran gelegen war, schon im Titel, also im Untertitel, so gewisse Botschaften mit hinein zu codieren. Ich meine, das macht man halt so, wenn man eine Konferenz macht. Aber das ist natürlich jetzt in dem Kunstding auch nochmal besonders wichtig, wie ich finde. Was waren so die Titel der letzten Jahre? Kriegst du noch alle zusammen?
Ja, Inspire, dann gab es Deep North, dann gab es Futurity Now und jetzt haben wir Response Ability. Alle relativ englischsprachigen Titel.
Na ja, da steckt sozusagen dann auch deine Hand mit drin.
Ja, die waren auch davor eher englisch-Titeln, aber die sind manchmal einfach schwer in anderen Sprachen. Nicht nur Deutsch, aber da ist auch ein gewisses Wortspiel manchmal auch dabei.
Na klar.
Die Mehrdeutigkeit ist sehr wichtig.
Ja, die Mehrdeutigkeit, das haben wir ja auch beim Chaos-Communication-Kongress mit dem Prinzip der Mehrdeutigkeit da auch sehr hoch.
Ja, bei allen Fällen.
Da gelingt es auch nicht immer, was Gutes zu finden, was auch im deutschen und englischen Sprache um gleichem Maße abbildbar ist. Jetzt gibt es diesen Begriff Medienkunst. Man sieht an dieser Transmediale Video quasi so als das erste typisch künstlerische Technologie. Also so Filme machen, das war schon immer auch irgendwie Kunst. Bilder schaffen, Geschichten erzählen, das gehört irgendwie dazu. Mit der Popularisierung dieser Technologien merkt man ja, geht dann auch immer ein entsprechender Schub in so eine Kunstszene hinein. Das war dann eben mit dem Aufkommen des Internets nicht sehr viel anders. Es gab früher dann auch schon so Pioniere der Netzkunst, die aber für meinen Dafürhalten immer noch im Wesentlichen damit beschäftigt waren, überhaupt erst mal zu definieren, was denn das vielleicht überhaupt sein könnte. Also man hatte den Begriff erst mal vorangeschoben und gesagt, sowas müsste es wohl geben. Und jetzt denken wir mal drüber nach, was es vielleicht ist. Und dann fühlt sich das irgendwie so langsam von selbst. So eine Self-Fulfilling Prophecy vielleicht an der Stelle auch. Mittlerweile haben wir es aber nahezu mit einer Demokratisierung dieser Technologien zu tun, in einem Maße, wo eigentlich fast überhaupt nichts mehr teuer und unerschwinglich unerreichbar ist. Und dazu natürlich auch noch mit einer Vernetzung und einer Rekombinierbarkeit von allem. Wie hat sich das ausgewirkt? Oder vielleicht gehen wir auch nochmal so einen Schritt zurück. Wann ging es denn überhaupt los? Also seit wann gibt es überhaupt etwas, was man Medienkunst nennen könnte? Also wann begann Technik und Kunst einen gemeinsamen Weg zu gehen?
Na ich meine, das sind zwei sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Fragen. Die eine Frage ist, wenn nannte sich dieses Kunst Medienkunst? Also sich selbst? Also wenn definierte so die Künstler, die mit diesem Zeug zu tun hat, als Medienkünstler? Ich muss gestehen, ich weiß es nicht. Ich würde vermuten, dass es wahrscheinlich um den 50er-, 60er-Jahre, vielleicht um Nanjing Pike, war, sozusagen, dass der Medienkünstler in diesem Sinn geboren ist. Aber wenn, natürlich, wie lange arbeiten Künstler mit Technologie zusammen? Da kann man so von Tausende von Jahren reden. Und wenn man einen Vortrag von Siegfried Zylinski anhört, die sozusagen Medienarchäologie unter anderem forscht, der fängt bestimmt mindestens vor 500, wenn nicht 1000 Jahre davor. Für mich persönlich hat das sehr viel oder diese Art von sogenannten Medienkunst, ich muss sagen auch, das ist nicht besonders ein Begriff, die ich sehr oft nutze. Also ich weiß selber nicht so wirklich, was damit gemeint ist. Es ist so eine Schubladisierung von irgendwas. Ich bin in Kunst interessiert, ich bin Technologie interessiert und ich bin in einer künstlerischen Auseinandersetzung zwischen diesen Sachen interessiert und was daraus entsteht. Und was mich besonders auch im Kontext von Transmediale und auch diese anderen Sachen, die wir damals mit Ostroninien gemacht haben, ist die Auseinandersetzung mit einer Art von elektronischen Medien oder Medium, die halt auf den Fluss von Ionen beeinflusst ist. Und deswegen kann es auch nicht Film in sich sein, weil Film ist einfach ein Stück Plastik, durch den man schauen kann. Aber ich bin interessiert in das elektromagnetischen Band und diese Materie von Ionen, die sozusagen eine gewisse Kommunikation hervorgeben, ob das Ton ist oder ein visuelles Bild, was das auch für visuelle Texturen hat und warum man das in bestimmten Art und Weise benutzt, um bestimmte Sachen zu erzielen. Weil natürlich die Reproduzierbarkeit von elektronischen Medien ist natürlich etwas anderes als Film, das war auch eine interessante grundsätzliche Unterschied in den damaligen Ostblock, wenn man davon reden darf, das alte Ost- und Mitteleuropa-Trennung, wo Film seit Lange eine wichtige Tradition hat, die auch eine gewisse politische Tradition in der Kunst ab einer bestimmten Zeit hat und der Gefährlichkeit an der anderen Seite von Sendemedien, also wie man Menschen durch elektronische Sende beeinflussen oder manipulieren kann. Das gab so einen grundsätzlichen Unterschied in der Startlöcher von Künstlern, die entscheiden, ich werde Filmemacher sein, weil ich will eine bestimmte Geschichte erzählen, ich will eine bestimmte Ästhetik haben, oder ich will mit bestimmten Arten von Bildern experimentieren. Oder einer, der sagt, ja, nein, ich brauche diese Technologie, um meine kreative Message zu geben, weil das hat auch einfach einen anderen Kontext, einen anderen Ziel, ein anderes Publikum. Und da arbeite ich auch mit ganz anderer Materie, auch wenn die beiden letztendlich Bilder produzieren. Aber die Bilder sind auch sehr unterschiedlich. Diese Unterschiede gibt es ja nicht mehr so richtig, auch in der Art, wie die Konvergenz der Technologien sind. Also Filmemacher arbeiten im Prinzip mit Video. Und Videokünstler oder Videomachers arbeiten sogar manchmal mit Film. Also das ist die Art, wie die Sachen produziert werden. Letztendlich, das hat sich ziemlich zueinander verschmolzen. Aber das ist etwas, was seit vielleicht 15 Jahren oder so gibt. Und so mein Einstieg in diese Welt, und das, was auch Transmediale sehr geprägt hat, ist ja eher dieser nicht-filmische, technologische Blick. Obwohl wir auch manchmal auch Filme zeigen, wenn Inhalten mit dem Thematik zu tun hat. Und es gibt es auch heute, und das ist auch manchmal sehr interessant, wir wollten eigentlich letztes Jahr mit die Berlinale auch so ein Programm zusammen machen, in dem wir beide dieselbe Kunstwerke zeigen. Aber eine kommt aus dem filmischen Kontext und Peripherie von der Berlinale. Und die, die wir als Transmediale zeigen, kommt aus diesem elektronischen, technologischen Kontext. Es könnte genau dieselbe Kunstwerk sein, und es gibt viele Künstler, die halt ganz bequem sind, in die Berlinale zu sein. Also vielleicht nicht in dem großen Filmprogramm, aber in Form Expanded oder so. Und auch in die Transmediale. Aber die werden natürlich dort anders gesehen und anders kontextualisiert. Und dieser Begriff von Medienkunst wird dann sozusagen dadurch so fuzzy. Ja, was für eine Medien redet man? Redet man davon von Journalismus, dass die Medien oder kennen auch, dass das Medium auch der Emotion von Filmen sei. In der Tradition steckt man sich da rein. Ich meine, Nam June Paik hat auch mit Filmen als Materie gearbeitet, aber seine künstlerische Ausdruck hat sehr viel mit der Übertragung und der Senderfähigkeit von bestimmten Bildern zu tun. Deshalb für mich auch die Telefonbilder von dem damals Bauhausmeister und Künstler Laszlo Mochulinaj sind auch für mich eine der besten, heutzutage immer noch eine der besten quasi Medien-Kunstwerke. Es ist eigentlich eher so eine Art Telekommunikationskunst, die er hat, indem er die damalige neuste Technologie von Telefon benutzt hat.
Also damals, wir reden von den 20er Jahren.
Genau, 1926, ein super einfaches Projekt, der hat einfach zwei Stück Papiere, in denen ein Raster war, so ein ganz normaler Millimeterpapier, indem er eine Kodierung war, die er halt zu einer Schildmacher geschickt hat. Und der hat per Telefon die Kodierung zu dem einzelnen Quadrat gegeben, also welche Farbe soll in welche Quadrate reingepinselt werden. Der Maler meiste hat kein Muster. Also normalerweise, wenn du machst halt ein Bild für ein Schild, du kriegst schon so eine Zeichnung von dem Ding. Aber er hat das sozusagen per Telefon anhand eine reine alphanumerische Kodierung übergeben.
Das heißt, er hat sozusagen ein Bild gerastert, ein Bild gemalt oder ein Muster gemalt auf Millimeterpapier und das quasi in X und Y in den Pixel zerlegt und dann einfach angerufen und über Telefon jeden einzelnen Pixel übertragen sozusagen.
Genau.
Pixel mit der Koordinate XY hat folgende Farbe. Dann wurde es auf der anderen Seite entsprechend auch sozusagen das erste Fax.
Ja, so ein Telefonbild hat.
Faxi-Geläber, Telefon.
Und ich meine, so rein konzeptuell und was wir heute so tun mit Telekommunikation und so weiter, das ist ja schon sehr stark als Arbeit und damals war es so, dass das Bild, das entstanden worden ist, sah aus ziemlich viel wie die andere Bilder von Moholi Nagy, die waren nicht so der großen Hammer, aber die Leute waren schon etwas schockiert von der Tatsache, dass das nicht von Moholi Nagy's Hand gepinselt war, sondern von so einer Male. Und Moholi Nagy verkaufte das oder zeigte das sozusagen als sein Werk. Es kann sein, dass es auch seine Sekretärin war, die den Code durchgegeben hat, es ist völlig egal, wer das gemacht hat.
Das heißt, das ist das erste Mal, wo Kunst und Künstler so entkörpert, so voneinander getrennt wurden, wo so eine virtuelle Kommunikationsebene eingezogen wurde und man sich mit dem Gedanken erst mal anfreunden musste, dass das nicht unbedingt immer von Hand gemalt sein muss.
Genau, also das gehört alles dazu, aber es wird selten über diese Kunstwerk, was weiß ich, ein Medienkunstwerk.
Da haben sie dann bestimmt alle gesagt, das ist doch keine Kunst.
Bestimmt. Und das kann sein, dass der Schildermeister das auch einfach krass ein Schild gesehen hat, weil das war auch in dem Mai, die waren auch in dem Mai gemacht, E-Mail gemacht. Aber das ist dann natürlich auch wieder diese Frage, kann jeder Künstler sein oder nicht? Nein, die Antwort ist nein. Mahal Inaj ist der Künstler, das ist ein konzeptueller Verfahren, die er auch so als Kunst definiert. Der machte das nicht aus dem Notwendigkeit, irgendwie ein Schild produzieren zu müssen, sondern er hat einen ganz klaren, künstlerischen Auftrag.
Weißt du, wie viele Pixel das letzten, wie fein hat er das aufgelöst, dieses Schild?
Weiß ich nicht so genau.
Das muss ja ewig gedauert haben, das zu übertragen.
Wenn man die Bilder sieht, die sind so ungefähr, ich glaube, so ungefähr so A4 Größe, vielleicht bis zu A3 so ungefähr. Und die sind halt die typische, so abstrakte, quasi konstruktivistische Raumbilder von Moholi Naj. Das muss nicht unbedingt eine sehr, sehr feine Raste sein. Und ich nehme mal an, der hat wahrscheinlich waren die ersten eher grober als die späteren, weil der hat mehrere von diese Bilder produziert. Aber es ging halt da sehr einfach um dieses Konzept, also mehr als das, was der endgültige Bild ist.
Das überhaupt gemacht zu haben, mal zu zeigen, was Sache ist.
Ich meine, das ist zu einer Zeit, als das Bauhausgebäude war eben gerade ein Jahr alt und schon so eine Art Leerstück der Moderne. Es war nicht gedacht, dass es ein sehr funktionales Gebäude sein soll, sondern ein Demonstrationsobjekt, wie bestimmte Technologien für den Bau funktionieren sollten, so richtig so High-Tech-Building und dieses Gebäude hat Telefone installiert gehabt. Also es kam sozusagen mit in den Kit. Also nicht nur Lichtschalter, sondern es gab so kleine Türchen in den Wand und da waren Telefone drin. Und gerade genau in demselbe Art, wie diese Künstler und Lehrer damit fotografischen Prozessen experimentiert haben, die mit all diesen Dingen und auch diese Telefonzeugs experimentiert haben. Naja, auf jeden Fall was daran, also neben der Kontextualisierung von künstlerischem Prozess, es gibt auch einfach der Neugier, mit Technologie auseinanderzusetzen. Also diese Geräte, die wir in unserem Alltag haben, die einfach auseinanderzunehmen und die zu anderen Zwecken zu bringen, als vielleicht das, wozu die ursprünglich gedacht waren. Das ist natürlich auch eine wichtige Teil von dieser künstlerischen Auseinandersetzung mit Technologie, die vielleicht zu anderen Deutungen für die Technologie ziehen kann.
Na, da sind wir jetzt schon direkt bei der Hackerkultur gelandet, weil, wie Vau immer so schön sagt, das atypische Benutzerverhalten an den Tag zu legen und die Dinge für ganz was anderes zu verwenden, als sie ursprünglich mal gedacht waren, das steckt ja immer auch mit drin. Kennst du vielleicht auch den Text Hackers and Painters?
Den Text Hackers?
Ja, Hackers and Painters, von Paul Graham, so einer der Hacker-Philosophen vielleicht auch, also selber auch ein sehr erfolgreicher Programmierer, der sehr viele schöne Essays schreibt, auch immer noch, immer wieder mal mit so ein paar interessanten Bildern kommt, der schon immer auch so diesen künstlerischen Aspekt des Hackertums stark betont hat. Und Hackers and Painters ist ein Buch von ihm, es gibt auch so ein kürzeres Essay, wo er im Prinzip auch so die Arbeit eines Programmierers überhaupt erst mal anders beschreibt und eben trennt von dieser reinen Ingenieurs-mäßigen Arbeit wieder, sodass man da so Code produziert, sodass man eben eigentlich als Hacker auch sehr viel mehr arbeitet, eben wie so ein Painter, wie ein Maler. Das heißt, man verbringt eben auch viel Zeit mit Denken und lässt die Dinge erst mal so zu sich kommen, um dann eben so dieses Bild zu bringen. Also auch da ist eben so dieser Technologe, der Hacker, der sozusagen voll in der Technologie steckt, auf einmal durch so einen Betrachtungswinkel vollständig eben in so einem künstlerischen Prozess wieder angesiedelt. Und ich denke, jeder, der auch selber programmiert, weiß jetzt auch genau, was damit gemeint ist, weil es ist nicht so eine reine mechanische Umsetzung von irgendeiner Idee, für die es dann eben so eine genaue Lösung gibt, sondern es ist einfach ein hochgeistiger, kreativer Prozess, der halt auch bei dem einen so und bei dem anderen so ausfällt. Man kennt eben auch die unterschiedlichen Qualitätsstufen von Software, die sich eben auch in der Kreativität des Künstlers selbst eben letzten Endes auch neu definieren. Ja, diese Telefonbilder finde ich ja schon mal sehr genial. Ich meine, das ist ja sozusagen dann wirklich der erste Schritt, wo man sagt, okay, ich male eigentlich ein Bild, aber seine eigentliche künstlerische Bedeutung bekommt es eben durch die Entstehungsweise. Hätte er es jetzt einfach nur so auf dem Blatt Papier gemalt, dann wäre es halt einfach so ein Bild seiner Zeit gewesen. Jetzt hast du vorhin schon häufiger den Namen June Pyke benannt, Amerikaner, koreanischer Herkunft. Welche Rolle spielte der denn in dieser Entwicklung?
Ja, ich meine, ich habe den Namen June Pyke deswegen da rein geworfen, weil wir auch über diese Begrifflichkeiten gesprochen haben. Man könnte sagen, dass der Name June Pyke vielmehr der klassische Künstler ist, was auch immer ein klassischer Künstler so sein mag, wo er die Gerätschaften von Technologie im Prinzip komplett losgelöst hat von dessen Funktionen und in einer reinen abstrakten und künstlerischen Art und Weise umgesetzt hat. Und das ist so, wo eine der ersten, die halt mit entweder elektronischen Soundinstrumenten oder Fernsehern sozusagen in fast so skulpturaler Art und Weise gearbeitet hat. Man kann aber auch bestreiten, dass Nam June Paik dann wirklich ein Medienkünstler war, weil vielleicht, also es gibt ja ein Camp, in dem viel mehr politische und sozio-gesellschaftliche Auseinandersetzung mit dem Begriff auch kommt. Und deswegen sage ich das, vielleicht mehr so klassische Künstler, weil der war auch ein Gallery-Artist und der verkehrte mit seinem Werk sehr in eine damals übliche Kunstwelt, Kunstkontext, was ja völlig in Ordnung ist. Und das, was du meinst mit dem Hacker-Kultur, die auch eine sehr wichtige und sehr künstlerische Aspekte hat, das ist zum Beispiel nicht unbedingt etwas, was in so einer Gallery-Kontext ist. Und das ist, wo es anfängt interessant zu sein. Weil gerade das, was die Hackers machen und die, die das, wo sie selbst sagen, dass wir machen das in poetischer Art und Weise oder sogar in künstlerischer Art und Weise, ich glaube, da steckt ja das eigentliche Wesen der Medienkünste, die halt mit Technologie zu tun haben, weil gerade durch eine hacktivistische Auseinandersetzung mit Prozessen, also nicht nur die Technologien, aber auch die Prozessen innerhalb von Technologien, damit entsteht halt im Prinzip neue Bilder. Ich meine, Bilder nicht unbedingt in so visueller Sinn, aber als Modelle und Kontexte, vokabulären Sprachen und so weiter. Und das ist vielleicht eine viel schärfere künstlerische Auseinandersetzung als der, der in dem Schutz der Galerie ein Kunstwerk entsteht. Obwohl es natürlich auch Aktivist-Artists gibt, die auch in dem Kunstgalerie-Kontext arbeiten. Also da ist natürlich viel Vermischung. Und eine Veranstaltung, ein Festival wie die Transmediale, der hat fast von Anfang an auch mit solchen Künstlern auseinandergesetzt. Da gab es ja noch nicht so richtig dieses Hack- oder Hacktivist-Begriff, das ist auch etwas, durch bestimmte Notwendigkeiten, später gekommen ist. Aber ich glaube, in 1993 war auch der australische Künstler Stellarck in Berlin bei der Transmediale und Stellarck ist Künstler, also der nennt sich Künstler, man kann das nicht bestreiten. Und der macht fast nichts anderes als seine Körper, als eine Art technologisches Objekt sozusagen zu haken und damit neue Körper zu bauen und Exoskeletons zu kreieren, die sozusagen seinen Körper angreift oder mit dem Körper arbeitet, um das neue Wesen zu produzieren. Also das, was er tut, ohne was heutzutage wie das Hacking zu sehen ist, er mag das seit langem einigen in seiner Kunst, weil das ist halt einfach der Ausdrucksweise seiner künstlerischen Auseinandersetzung.
Er ist eigentlich so die Menschmaschine.
Eine der Ersten, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich war auch extrem beeindruckt, dass ich das erste Mal live gesehen habe, da war ich noch etwas unvorbereitet auf diese Performance. Das war so die Zeit, wo er sich vor allem durch Computer über MIDI ferngesteuert, seine Muskeln fernsteuern ließ und sich quasi von der Maschine und dann eben auch durch Einbindungen des frühen Internets, eben auch durch Fernwirkungen quasi irgendwelchen Leuten hat Bewegungen vorschreiben lassen, die er dann nicht bewusst ausgeführt hat, sondern die sein Körper halt einfach getan hat und er konnte gar nichts dagegen tun, weil einfach diese Kontakte auf seinen Muskeln klebten und die Ströme, die Muskeln einfach zur Zuckung gezwungen haben. Trotzdem war er dann auch überhaupt nicht davon abzubringen. Als ich dann gesehen hatte in Luxemburg, da werde ich nie vergessen, da war dann seine Zeit irgendwie vorbei, aber er war irgendwie der Meinung, das müsse jetzt weitergehen. Also manisch, überhaupt nicht zu bremsen, aber trotzdem einfach auch eine unglaubliche Disruption wiederum. Da sind wir wieder bei diesem Ostraninja, also das Publikum, glaube ich, war sich immer sehr unsicher, wie sie jetzt überhaupt mit dieser Situation umgehen sollte, weil er so was Brutales hatte, er hat sich auch immer in seinem Fleischerhaken, in Australien, im Hafen irgendwie aufhängen lassen, also den Haken durch den Körper sozusagen, also mehr Verwirrung kann man glaube ich fast gar nicht stiften.
Was in bestimmte Hindu-Ritualen so normal ist. Und dann wird gefragt, ist das denn der Kost? Also das Nagelbett und so. Aber niemand wird bestreiten, dass das Stellarck kein Künstler ist. Und man könnte ja auch sagen, dass die diverseste Definition von was Medienkunst ist, was auch immer das ist, ist wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo in Stellarcks Werk mit verankert. Und das deutet natürlich auf die unglaubliche Bandbreite oder Multidisziplinarität, die in dieses Begriff sich bergt. Und man kann halt einfach einzelne Elemente davon rausnehmen und damit sich bedienen, auf die Suche nach der richtigen Definition oder auf das Gesamtkonzept, den Gesamtkunstwerk vielleicht schauen, dass das die technologisierte Multimedia-Kunst ist oder Mixed Media sein soll oder kann. Weil auf Englisch, wenn man sagt Mixed Media, das kann halt Stein, Papier und Holz bedeuten, was natürlich nicht so leicht aus Multimedia durchgehen würde. Deswegen mag ich diese Begriffe nicht, weil die bringen uns nicht wirklich weiter. Da entsteht nur Krüttelmuddel vor unseren Kräften. Es gab sogar, das ist auch etwas, was ich bei den Transmedialen in den 90er-Jahren gesehen habe, da gab es den Bereich CD-ROM-Art. Und das hat mich damals auch ein bisschen irritiert. Oder vielleicht verunsichert, weil ich dachte, CD-ROM-Art, das wäre, als ob ich sagen würde, VHS-Art. Ich meine, klar, VHS hat auch so eine Art so Ästhetik, gewisserweise, so von seiner Materie. Aber CD-ROM hat ja nur den Träger. Man schiebt das in den Rechner ein und der Rechner macht irgendwas damit. Und das kann entweder ein Video sein oder so ein Software-Stück oder vielleicht etwas, das sich mit dem Internet andockt.
Heute müsste man das wahrscheinlich USB-Stick-Art nennen.
Ja, also das wäre so dasselbe. Aber es gab in der Tat so seriöse Künstler, die Stipendien auch gekriegt haben und auch Stellung gemacht haben zu CD-ROM-Art.
Da steckt aber wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen dieses Problem drin, dass man natürlich als Künstler gegenüber so einer Öffentlichkeit und Gesellschaft auch immer wieder in so einer Bringschuld ist, zu erklären, was man denn da eigentlich macht und warum das wichtig ist. Und man natürlich dann irgendwo auch mit den etablierten, den wenigen etablierten Begriffen handeln muss, die in dieser Gesellschaft schon angekommen sind. Das ist ja nun CD-ROM definitiv eines dieser Worte, was zumindest für einige Jahre verfangen hat, wo dann die Leute sich was drunter vorstellen konnten. Während, wenn man es wahrscheinlich auf die digitale Speicherung als solche heruntergebrochen hätte, die Leute schon wieder komplett ausgestiegen wären.
Ja, ich meine, diese Dinge, diese Disks, die hatten auch eine andere gesellschaftliche Code damals. Das war Cutting-Edge-Technologie, auch für Sound.
CD-Qualität.
Wir hatten wirklich nur damit angefangen. Der Tape-Player Walkman war gerade on the way out. Und es gab sozusagen die CD-ROM Walkmans. Aber es ist halt durch diese Aufnahme in die Gesellschaft, dass das dann auch in einer gewissen Weise, nehme ich mal an, in diesen Kunstkontext reingekommen ist. Wir hatten davor, also vor CD-ROM Art, ich glaube nicht, dass wir Floppy-Disc-Art hatten. Wir hatten schon Computer-Kunst und Robotics und so. Aber ich kenne mich nicht an Floppy-Disc-Art. Aber okay, ich meine, das ist schnell ausgestorben, den CD-ROM Art.
Und was ist es heute? Was ist die CD-ROM Art of today?
Ich hoffe, dass wir zurückkommen. Oder wir haben einfach Kunst, die sich nicht kategorisieren lässt anhand der einzelnen bestimmten Medien oder Technologien, mit denen das betrieben wird. Sondern diese geistige, kritische, manchmal reflexive, reflektive Auseinandersetzung zu gesellschaftlichen Prozessen, zu Tatsachen, zu Situationen, neue Vokabuläre, neue Sichtweisen zu etablieren. Das ist der Stoff von Kunst, die da nicht unbedingt in eine angewandte Situation sich hinbiegen muss. Es kann genau das Gegenteil wirken, um die Anwendung in ein anderes Licht zu rücken. Das kann ein politischer Weg sein, oder politischere muss nicht unbedingt sein. Auch mit Transmediale gegenüber anderen Arten von Festivals, die mit Kunst zu tun haben, ist der Fokus in dieser Auseinandersetzung zwischen Mensch, Gesellschaft, Technologie. Diese Technologie muss nicht unbedingt der Wahrheit sein für einen künstlerischen Ausdruck. Aber das ist das, was unsere Gesellschaft, unsere Lebensmodus definiert. Das ist der Stoff unserer Lebens. Deswegen ist es wichtig, mit diesen Zeug auseinanderzusetzen. Ich glaube, gleichzeitig haben auch viele Leute damit Probleme. Die kennen solche Dinge nur als das. Warum würde ich daraus Kunst machen? Ich habe hier diese ganz skurrile, deutsche Stecker, die mich übrigens auch total irritiert hat, warum dieses Ding notwendig ist, wenn eine Stecker ja schon hier ist.
Das irritiert mich auch. Wahrscheinlich 99% der Zuhörer. Aber es muss ja jetzt auch einen Grund gegeben haben, dass du jetzt konkret da Kunst mit dem Aspekt, hier werden Medien, hier wird Technologie verwendet, dass das für dich jetzt eine besondere Deutung hat. Da muss ja auch eine Faszination ausgehen, wenn man sich da so intensiv mit beschäftigt. Wovon geht diese Faszination konkret aus? Und vielleicht kannst du auch mal ein paar Projekte benennen, die so in der Geschichte oder auch der jüngeren Zeit, die für dich jetzt so besonders exemplarisch sind für die Art von Kunst, von der du denkst, dass die eben auch Relevanz hat, dass die Dinge bewegt, die toll sind, Spaß machen.
Ich meine, so mein persönlicher Drive da drin ist natürlich nicht unbedingt dasselbe mit das, was ich tue insgesamt mit etwas wie ein Festival, die natürlich sehr viele, wir wollen sehr viele Sachen an viele unterschiedliche Publikums ranbringen. Aber für mich persönlich ist schon, könnte man sagen, diese politische, emanzipatorische Macht von Kunst sehr wichtig. Und deswegen bin ich hauptsächlich in die digitale Künste und die technologische Künste interessiert, weil das hat auch sehr viel mit Freiheit letztendlich zu tun. Freie Meinungsäußerung und Bewegung und so weiter. Das sehr viel, was wir tun, auch mit Transmediale und in meiner eigenen Arbeit, hat mit Zugang zu Technologie, Zugang zu Kommunikationsmitteln. Also es hat mit politische, emanzipatorische Prozessen auch. Das hat auch damit zu tun mit auch so Sachen wie Australienien. Ich hatte vorhin, oder vor wir online oder on air gegangen sind, die Fernsehrevolution in Rumänien als Beispiel benannt, was für mich so eine wichtige Meilenstein in sehr vielen unterschiedlichen Prozessen war. Nicht unbedingt eine künstlerische Prozess, aber das ist ein Moment, wo sich die Macht der Medien klar offenbart.
Kannst du mal konkret benennen, was du meinst mit Fernsehrevolution in Rumänien?
Damit meine ich halt den Moment in der Stürz von Nicolae Ceaușescu in Dezember 89, dass diese Revolution wurde vollbracht in dem Moment, dass den Kontroll über der Fernsehanstalt gemacht worden ist. Also die Prochisten sozusagen, das Volk, also diese komische Bande von Militärs, Oppositionelle und Bürger haben sich sozusagen vor die Fernsehkamera gestellt und alle sozusagen geschubst und geschubst und geschubst. Wer kann sozusagen vor die Kamera sein? Das sah so ein bisschen so Comedy-mäßig aus. Aber es ging nicht darum, irgendwie den Präsidentenpalast zu stürmen oder den Regierungsgebäude, sondern es musste halt der Fernsehanstalt sein, um diese Revolution zu verkünden. Und das ist, das war natürlich auch sehr klug. Es war nicht die Art und Weise unbedingt, dass andere Revolutionen bis dahin verzogen worden sind. Und heute, also heute diese Woche, letzte Woche, redet man natürlich sehr oft von vielleicht eine ähnliche Art von Phänomenen, was der vollbrachte Twitter-Revolution in Tunesien ist. Da werden wir mal sehen, ob das wirklich so ist oder nicht. Das hat in Iran sozusagen bekanntlich nicht geklappt. Noch nicht. Sie fragen, wie lange dauert eine Revolution und wo geht man damit hin? Und diese Macht der Medien halt sozusagen umzusetzen, um so zivile Gesellschaft zu unterbinden. Also das sind so die Grundlage, die mich sozusagen interessiert. Und mein Vehikel, um das zu tun, hat sehr viel mit Raum für künstliche Prozesse entstehen zu lassen. Und das ist etwas, was vielleicht in Deutschland weniger notwendig ist, obwohl ich glaube, das ist auch hier wichtig. Aber durch das, was wir denn auch hier tun, da Menschen von anderen Situationen, anderen Kontexten da reinzuziehen oder in Zusammenarbeit zu machen, dass die mit diesen Kontexten vielleicht zu Hause auch arbeiten können. Und da sind in die Künste manchmal interessante Freiräume, was nicht unbedingt ein politischer Prozess auch sind. Also inwieweit kann ein künstlerisches Prozess, das vielleicht sehr ähnlich aussieht wie ein politisches Prozess, in der Tat zu einem politischen Prozess umbenutzt werden? Gibt es das? Kann man das tun? Also ich weiß nicht 100%ig.
Also man hat so eine Revolution durch Kunst, indem man das sozusagen recht disruptiv vorträgt.
Genau, das wollte ich halt nicht so in dem Sinne sagen. Das muss nicht unbedingt eine gewaltsame Sache. Aber der Tatsache, dass zum Beispiel in einer Stadt wie Karachi, in Pakistan, kleine Medienzentren oder Medienorganisationen sich etablieren, indem man zusammenkommen kann und im Prinzip arbeiten wie wir hier. Und wo jeder kann kommen und machen, was sie wollen, mehr oder weniger, und online kommen, unbekümmert, ohne Druck von außen, sei es religiöse Wächter oder Polizei oder so. Das sind Dinge, die auch in Kontexten von Kunst und kultureller Auseinandersetzung mit Medien und Technologie wichtig und erreichbar sind.
Mich erinnert das so ein bisschen an Orson Welles und sein Radiohörspiel War of the Worlds, was ja berühmt genug ist und auch zu Recht. Das war ja im Prinzip auch so eine Disruption der Öffentlichkeit unter Verwendung eben des noch relativ jungen Mediums Radio, wo dann alle so sehr in Angst und Schrecken versetzt wurden, weil diese realistische Darstellung dieses Buchs War of the Worlds, also Mars-Menschen kommen und übernehmen unseren Planeten, dass die Leute an der Stelle Realität und Kunst überhaupt nicht mehr auseinanderhalten konnten. Irgendwann haben sie sich wieder beruhigt, aber die Panik war nachhaltig. Das hätte man auch noch auf die Spitze treiben können, wenn man das irgendwie so einen Tag durchgehalten hätte. So was meinst du?
Ja, ich meine, das kam aus einer Zeit, in der es noch nicht viel Erfahrung mit dieser Art von Kommunikation und Übertragung gab.
So wie jetzt mit dem Internet. Jetzt hat man halt auch Angst, dass das böse Internet kommt.
Aber das war ein bisschen so, was wir damals mit dem Thema Conspire ansprechen wollten. Wir kommen immer mit dem Internet auch zurück zu der Problematik oder zu der Situation, dass es wichtig ist, dass der einzelne Mensch Kontroll über seine eigene Situation hat. Es ist letztendlich den alten Spruch, don't believe everything that you read. Und wenn wir bombardiert sind mit allen möglichen Nachrichten, alle möglichen Soundbites, die oft und fast immer außer Kontext genommen sind, dass man trotzdem ein bisschen denken muss, worum es geht und warum. Man muss auch die Geschichte hinter der Geschichte lesen. Vielleicht müssen wir das jetzt verstärkt machen, gerade wegen der An-Einfachheit zu den Möglichkeiten, seine eigene Message zu senden. Broadcast yourself. Es wird wenig diskutiert, was das wirklich bedeutet. Wer ist du, dass jeder wirklich sich broadcasten soll? Das ist ja auch nicht so gut. Wer soll dann noch zuhören? Das kommt auch dazu. Aber das steckt ein bisschen in das Thema dieses Jahr, wo es geht um Response und Ability. Also die Ability to respond in bestimmten Kontexten. Und dann hat diese Responsibility, also das hat mit gewisse Marktstrukturen, kommt ja auch in eine gewisse Art von Verantwortung. Und das eine Social Community, eine Social Media, kann eigentlich nur deswegen eigentlich funktionieren, weil das halt eine soziale Konstruktion ist, die halt auf bestimmte Art von menschlichen Auseinandersetzungen berührt. Und es ist nicht eine Wettrennen zu sehen, wie viele Freunde kann jemand haben zum Beispiel. Also wenn man schon 2000 Freunde hat, dann ist ja klar, dass da gibt es eine Differenzierung in deine Freundeskreisen irgendwie.
Aber Follower kann man nicht genug haben.
Ja, das ist interessant. Warum haben die nicht gesagt Follower? Das ist ein anderer Hierarchie dahinter. Wenn man diese zwei große Beispiele mit Facebook und Twitter nimmt, der eine ist wirklich dafür da, um bestimmte Anstoße von Gedanken, Informationen und so weiter zu teilen und weiter zu verbreiten, den Twitter-Modell. Facebook hat einfach einen ganz anderen Kontext, wo es wirklich darum ging, um ein ständiges Hin und Rück von Informationen und Ideen. Also nicht unbedingt eine und raus, das sind sehr viele unterschiedliche Wege, sondern es gibt immer diese Notwendigkeit um Rückkopplung, auch wenn es nicht mehr so unbedingt benutzt sein wird. Deswegen ist es wichtig, viele Follower zu haben, aber nicht unbedingt so viele Friends. Auf dem Weg hierher hörte ich einen Bericht über noch einmal so eine von den vielen anfängenden Alternative-Projekten wie Facebook, die natürlich immer noch klein sind und man würde sagen, auch die sind elitär. Ich hab jetzt nicht mehr im Kopf, wie dies hieß, aber das ist ein Social-Networking-Projekt, wo es auf nur 50 Freunde begrenzt ist. Also man darf nicht mehr aus 50 haben.
Das klingt sinnvoll. Das heißt, man muss sich die richtigen aussuchen.
Genau, aber das beruht sich auch auf mehrere Studien, die sagen, dass der normale Mensch im Prinzip nicht mehr als 50 vertrauenswürdige Bekannte hat. Es gibt diverse Kreise, fünf Leute, die engsten Buddies überhaupt. Zwölf bis 15 sind sehr gut befreundet. Es gibt der breitere Kreis von irgendwo zwischen 40 und 60. Die vertrauen sich wirklich gut. Danach gibt es nicht mehr richtig Friends, sondern Bekannte. Also wirklich nur losere Bekanntschaften. Wir kennen uns irgendwie von irgendwo.
Du meinst, das Social Network, das du ansprichst, heißt PATH? Und diese Zahl mit den 50 Leuten ist Dunbars Number. Interessant, ob das kommt. Aber jetzt wurde gerade das Thema der Transmediale dieses Jahr so hervorholt, also Responsibility, die Fähigkeit zu reagieren, überhaupt auch noch mit dem Information-Flow klarzukommen. Es gibt ja immer viele Leute, die sagen, da ist ja so viel, da komme ich ja nicht mehr mit klar. Oder ich verstehe das generell nicht und ich kann darauf nicht antworten. Aber dann eben auch Responsibility. Bei Responsibility fällt mir immer wieder ein, da bin ich jetzt wieder bei dieser Hacker-Kultur, die einerseits ihre Liaison mit Künstlern hat, weil das Arbeiten mit Software im Besonderen, aber auch generell das sich auseinandersetzen mit Technologie, diesen kreativen Prozess des atypischen Benutzerverhaltens eben auch ein sehr künstlerischer Prozess ist. Trotzdem, was eben auch in der Szene immer wieder stark zu sehen, ist, dass aus diesem Wissen um die Systematiken, das Wissen um die Technologie, die Zusammenhänge und damit eben auch den Möglichkeiten, auch den Missbrauchsmöglichkeiten eine Verantwortung auch erwächst, in der Gesellschaft sich entsprechend zu äußern und zu agieren, sich politisch einzumischen. Das ist das, was den Chaos Computer Club vor allem stark geprägt hat. Dass dort einfach Leute zusammenkommen, die nicht nur so, wir sehen hier die Möglichkeiten und wir machen jetzt ein Start-up und dann werden wir alle stinkend reich, sondern wir sehen die Möglichkeiten heute. Wir können uns ausmalen, was mögliche Implikationen sind. Und dann gibt es halt immer die Chancen und die Risiken. Da gibt es also das Tolle, da wollen wir irgendwie alle hin, da wollen wir das nutzen. Deswegen wollen wir auch Computer haben und lehnen das jetzt nicht ab. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es eben Risiken und Big Brother und die Überwachung und die Einschränkung des Privaten und die damit verlorene Freiheit. Und das ist etwas, das wollen wir eben verhindern. Und diese Verantwortung tragen wir eben zurück in den politischen Diskurs. Hier hört mal, wir sind die, die uns sich mal alles ganz genau anschauen. Wir haben uns folgende Gedanken gemacht. Inwieweit siehst du so etwas auch in der Kunstwelt? Spielt das da wirklich eine Rolle? Ist dieses Verständnis des Verhältnisses des Künstlers zur Gesellschaft so primär ein Mahnen des sich einmischendes, politisierendes Element? Oder ist die Selbstliebe dann doch vorrangig?
Ich meine, das ist vielleicht einer der Punkte, wo etwas wie den Chaos Computer Congress oder das, was da gemacht wird, stark von etwas wie die Transmediale auch differenziert ist. Dort beim Chaos Computer Club muss das so sein. Aber das ist das treibende Kraft dahinter. Das ist einer von den vielen wichtigen Aspekten davon. Und was wir versuchen, unter anderem mit Transmediale zu tun, ist, die diversen und wichtigen Wegen und Auseinandersetzungen, sei es diese politisch-aktivistische Art und Weise, die du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, oder vielleicht der andere hundertprozentige reine poetische, ästhetische Auseinandersetzung mit Technologie, zu sagen, dass die alle extrem wichtige Ausdrucksformen in unserem technologischen Leben heute sind, um Leute einfach mehr in diese Welt reinzuziehen, also so ein Publikum sozusagen zu begeistern über die Möglichkeiten, die die vielleicht selber finden können und sehen können in Technologie, ohne sozusagen nur von dem, was manchmal beim Chaos Computer Club den spezialisierten Freaks und Hacks da sind, wo kein Weg nach innen so von außen gibt für viele Leute. Also das ist noch schwierigere Wand da.
Ich wollte jetzt aber den Vergleich jetzt nicht zwischen den beiden Veranstaltungen primieren, sondern mehr so die Szene, die so dahintersteht.
Ja, aber das, was ich meine, ist, dass halt eine hat eine sehr starke definierte Szene und die andere hat keine stark definierte Szene. Das sind multiple Szenen, die oft überlappen, miteinander vermischen, oder wo halt eine Szene den Vokabular von einem anderen aufnimmt und was anderes auch zu machen. Das hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun, dass eine besser oder sowas ist als der andere. Ich finde nur, das ist das, was sehr interessant ist, seit die Transmediale angefangen hat, dass sich so viele unterschiedliche Szenen sich identifizierten, angefangen haben, sich manifestierten in sehr viele unterschiedliche Wege. Das ist derselbe mit der Blogger-Kultur. Da ist auch eine künstlerisch-kritische Szene da drin, als auch der mehr journalistische oder politischere Szene. Deswegen bin ich genauso interessiert als Person, die mit diesen Sachen zu tun hat, auch in der Republika, wie auch in der Chaos-Kompetik, wie auch in der Transmediale. Die sind alle innerhalb der Sorte von Kontexten, aber sprechen unterschiedlichen Gruppen, Menschen, Szenen an und versuchen, anderen Menschen da reinzubringen.
Also Republika, das muss man kurz erläutern, ist die seit ein paar Jahren hier in Berlin stattfindende, aus der Blogger-Szene heraus gewachsene Konferenz.
Jetzt ist mir den Faden und die Frage verloren gegangen.
Mir geht es darum, im Verständnis dafür zu bekommen, inwieweit die Kunst konkret eine Selbstverantwortung sieht, auch wirklich selber politisch arbeitet oder vielleicht auch nur mit der Technik verloren herumspielt und froh ist, dass man ohne Dayjob auch überleben kann auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. Vielleicht nochmal, wo wir jetzt so viel über Veranstaltungen und Transmediale geredet haben. Ich denke, zu dieser ganzen Medien-Kunstbewegung, wie man jetzt auch immer zu diesem Begriff stehen mag, spielt vor allem auch die Ars Electronica in Linz eine gewichtige Rolle, die ja quasi die erste Veranstaltung war. Diesen Begriff glaube ich im Rahmen einer Konferenz auch so primär nach vorne gestellt hat, weiß ich nicht ganz genau. Wie siehst du das? Wie siehst du die Bedeutung der Ars Electronica? Welche Rolle hat das gespielt?
Na ja, die Ars Electronica ist nicht das erste wirklich, sagen wir so, Festival für Medienkunst, aber es ist das erste, die wirklich so sich etabliert hat und bewahrt hat. Und die ganze große Bandbreite von dieser Auseinandersetzung zwischen Gesellschaft, Kunst und Technologie seit über 30 Jahren, also 1979 glaube ich, ist das gegründet worden. Und was für eine Rolle das hat, ist ein bisschen schwer zu sagen. Also ich finde das immer sehr interessant, dass international wird oft Transmediale und Ars Electronica verglichen oder beziehungsweise als zwei unterschiedlichen, aber ähnliche Veranstaltungen gesehen, wo einer ist, es ist ein bisschen so ein David und Goliath-Zusammenhang, weil Transmediale ist auch gewisserweise eine Mini-Veranstaltung gegenüber die Ars Electronica. Das ist eine richtige Institution mittlerweile, die auch keine andere, reine, städtische und fördernden Struktur in sich hat. Da kann man vielleicht besser die Ars Electronica mit etwas wie die ZKM vergleichen, als mit so einer Veranstaltung wie die Transmediale oder vielleicht ZKM, den Zentrum für Kunst und Medientechnologie in Karlsruhe, zusammen mit der Transmediale bildet vielleicht so eine Art von deutschen Ars Electronica. Aber die Ars Electronica hat auf jeden Fall sehr viele Themen zu gesellschaftlichen Diskussionen gebracht. Und durch dessen Größe natürlich viele Leute zielen darauf, um zu sehen, was ist das Neueste, die es gibt. Aber was soll ich zur Ars Electronica sagen?
Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist ja nicht jeder damit vertraut. Ich selber war zwei, drei Mal da zuletzt, um da hier die Goldelse für den Club abzuholen.
Das war auch sehr interessant, dass die Ars Electronica die Goldelse dafür gemacht hat. Man fragt sich nicht, warum das nicht früher?
Also der CCC hat, um es kurz mal zusammenzufassen, die Goldelse ist die Golden Nika. Also der Hauptpreis in der jeweiligen Kategorie. Und die Kategorie selbst gibt es noch gar nicht so lange. Das ist halt die Digital Communities Kategorie. Das gibt es seit ein paar Jahren. Das ging, glaube ich, zuerst an die Wikipedia. Dann kamen ein paar andere Projekte, die ich jetzt so im Einzelnen gar nicht kannte, die auch nicht so bekannt sind. Jetzt halt im letzten Jahr an den CCC, quasi auch so als Lifetime Award gedacht. Gar nicht, weil jetzt in dem Jahr irgendwas Konkretes passiert ist. Ja, was nicht. Wie hast du das aufgenommen?
Also wie gesagt, ich war sehr, sehr glücklich. Erstmals darüber. Und ich finde, dass da steckt auch gewisserweise eine wichtige Zukunft. Auch der Ars Electronica mit diesen Auseinandersetzungen, auch in Digital Communities. Aber ich würde mir wünschen, dass die das eigentlich viel stärker und viel seriöser nachgehen werden. Weil das ist eine Sache, einen Preis zu etablieren und eine Jury zusammenzusetzen, die dann halt so einen Preis ausloben. Aber wirklich reflektiert in der Programmatik der Ars Electronica ist das vielleicht noch nicht angekommen. Und das wünsche ich mir, das zu sehen. Und das ist in der Auseinandersetzung mit Digital Communities auf die Ars Electronica, das wird schon in einer sehr, also im Allgemeinen, ich rede sehr, sehr allgemein hier, in Social Media Kontexten. Aber zum Beispiel der wirkliche und schwierige und notwendigen Auseinandersetzung mit dem, was zum Beispiel das Open Web ist, das wird wenig da behandelt. Und das ist natürlich ein sehr wichtiger und angewandter Thema dazu, die alle Bereiche der Ars Electronica antastet. Also das bleibt sehr ein bisschen so in so kleinen Inkubatoren irgendwie oder so kleine Inseln. Und als das losging mit dem Digital Community zu dachten, na ja, super, da könnte man vielleicht an Gefahren, ich will natürlich die Leute von Ars Electronica gar nicht so unterstellen, aber die sind super, dass das Gefahr läuft, dass das ein bisschen vielleicht entweder irrelevant sein wird, wenn das Ding in sich nicht mehr damit auseinandersetzt oder dass das dann halt beliebig sein kann. Das ist, und die Ars Electronica hat damit was Gutes und Interessantes gemacht, aber da muss dahinter mehr Programmatik und mehr Ausstrahlung dann kommen. Also warum halt den Chaos Computer Club und so? Ich meine, dieses Wesen war dann nicht unbedingt so super präsent, denn innerhalb wirklich das ganze Ausstrahlung der Ars Electronica und da steckt auch gewisse Verantwortung dahinter, weil man will nicht unterstellt werden, dass man das nur macht, weil das irgendwie trendy ist. Und da wünsche ich mir sozusagen viel kritische Auseinandersetzung mit dieser Thematik. Und wenn es heißt, vielleicht müssen wir ein paar von anderen Kategorien abschaffen, die vielleicht weniger wichtig oder interessant sind, wenn wir schon dieses eine haben. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Kategorien so ein Festival verkraften kann. Der Critical Mass ist ja auch irgendwann.
Kommen wir vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen mehr zurück zu dieser Kunst, Medienkunst, wie auch immer man es jetzt nennen mag, als solcher. Also ich habe das aus meiner Hacker-Perspektive auch schon immer so begleitet. Am Anfang hatte ich eben auch, als das noch so sehr visuell geprägt war und so extrem experimentell mit so diesen frühen Netzkunstanwandlungen, muss ich sagen, das hat mich immer nicht so richtig gerissen. Und was mich konkret immer gestört hat, war, dass ich eben viele Leute, die in diesem Bereich forschend konkret Projekte entwickeln tätig waren, dass ich, ich will es nicht als Vorwurf verstanden wissen, es war einfach nur so eine Beobachtung, dass diese Leute eben sich nicht in dem Maße wirklich in dieser Technologie auskannten, da nicht so tief drin stecken und man es eben ihren Werken auch ansah. Es war wirklich eine Beschäftigung von außen, hatte man so in einem, da waren ein paar interessante Ideen drin. Konkret zeigt sich dann halt immer so an diesem, dieses typische Medienkunstprojekt, ist so, der Künstler hat eine Idee, das hat irgendwie was mit Computern zu tun. Und dann holt man sich so den Programmierer und sagt ihm, mach mal. Und das merkt man an diesem Endprodukt auch irgendwie an, weil es ist einfach nicht durchlebt von dem, was wie so ein Programmierer an die Sache herangegangen wäre. Und die Sachen gehen irgendwie nicht auf. In den letzten Jahren wiederum merke ich, dass wir jetzt schon an einer Zeit angekommen sind, wo die Leute, die auch in diesen Kunstuniversitäten landen und die wirklich also Aspiration haben und Inspiration haben, die einfach was bewegen wollen und sich in dieser Form auch ausdrücken wollen, dass die eben einfach damit groß geworden sind. Für die ist das Internet eine Selbstverständlichkeit. Die sind eben mit den Gepflogenheiten und auch den Widrigkeiten aufgewachsen. Für die ist auch die Herangehensweise an Elektronik, Software generell einfach was Normales geworden, natürlich auch mit unterschiedlichen Qualitäten. Und jetzt entstehen Dinge und Werke von Leuten, wo ich ein bisschen aufatme und sage, okay, alles klar, vielleicht geht das jetzt auch erst los mit dem Medienkurs. Also, es würde mich mal interessieren, wie du das siehst und auch nochmal so ein bisschen die Frage, ob du auch so ein paar exemplarische Projekte dir da einfallen, die vielleicht diesen Wandel oder eben auch schon frühe Schritte ganz gut repräsentiert haben, die jetzt so besonders waren.
Ja, also, meine, was du beschreibst und vor allem den Kontext aus dem du kommst, kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen. Es gibt ja auch Kunstwerke, die besser oder stärker besser funktionieren als anderen auch. Das ist immer so mit allen Kunstwerken. Und natürlich da, wo ein Künstler ein Programmierer holt, um ein Ding zu machen, vielleicht ohne zu wissen, warum er dieses Programmierer braucht. Die tendieren mehr zu scheitern als das, wo du hast einen Künstler, der mit der Technologie vielleicht nicht auseinandersetzen kann. Aber der muss irgendwas tun. Der muss zu Punkt B kommen. Er ist klug genug zu wissen, dass er genau so eine Art Programmierer braucht, um diesen Prozess zu vollenden. Da gibt es bessere Chancen, dass das Ding seinen Message trägt. Aber ob wir vielleicht eine bessere Medienkunst sehen werden, weil wir in der Born-Digital-Generation angekommen sind, ist schwer zu sagen. Viele Leute sehen das Ding, so eine zugeklappte Mark-Book. Das ist eine magische Blackbox, mit der man alles machen kann. Als du, du und ich als Kinder waren, haben wir mit Transistoren gespielt, gebastelt, zusammengelötet und kleine Lämpchen gemacht, was man heute eigentlich nicht mehr macht. Weil man hat diese Geräte, die auf selbe Prozess funktionieren, aber die Microchips sind so klein, so kompliziert, dass siebenjährige Kinder nicht unbedingt sofort zu Radio Shack gehen, um damit zu basteln. Das heißt, da ist mehr Magie in das Hardware und das Geräte. Und vielleicht mehr Denken und Auseinandersetzungen im Prozess von Sachen. Und es wird, glaube ich, immer so sein, dass die erfolgreichsten Werke die sind, wo man merkt, dass der Künstler konzeptuell stark agiert und gleichzeitig auch Kontrolle über seine Medien hat, sei es Hardware, Software, Programmierprozesse und so weiter. Und das ist wieder ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, dass diese Kunstwerke super und besser sind. Aber da sind manchmal einfach ganz einfache Sachen, die interessant sind, einfach für die Art und Weise, wie der Künstler das kontaktisiert hat. Es gibt ein ganz, ganz simples Werk, das ich immer noch faszinierend finde, auch wegen der Geschichte, die da rumgespannt ist. Das ist letztendlich ein Video-Arbeit. Also eine 8-Millimeter-Videoarbeit, die online auch ist. Das Ding heißt Safe Distance. Ich weiß nicht, ob du von dem schon gehört hast. Das stammt aus 1999. Das ist eine kollaborative Arbeit, eine Zusammenarbeit zwischen der Kunst- und Mediengruppe und Zentrum Kuda in Novi Sad in Serbien und den US-amerikanischen Luftwaffen. Safe Distance ist nichts anderes als der letzte 31 Minuten von dem Cockpit Flight Recorder des abgeschossenen Stealth Bombers, die während der NATO-Bombardierung von Jugoslawien von ganz einfachen Menschen auf dem Boden mit ganz einfachen Schießgewehren abgeschossen worden ist. Da ist irgendwie diese Flugzeug, den Tarnkapper-Bomber, die eigentlich unsichtbar ist, abgeschossen worden. Die Piloten sind gerettet, also sind rausgesprungen worden. Die Flugzeuge crashen, heute haben sie das Wrack gefunden. Jemand hat diese Videokassette gefunden, und es wanderte in die Hände von diesen Leuten, die das Kunstwerk herausgegeben haben. Und was will ich damit sagen? Das ist ein Werk, das die Kranikünstler selbst aufnehmen können. Da gibt es gewisse Authentizität und Originalität. Und eine Sprache von diesen Piloten, die sich mit den Abschuss auseinandersetzen. Und der Kontext, dass diese unsichtbare Technologie überhaupt abschussbar ist, da kommen also diese Sachen mitte rein in dieses Werk. Und das hat vielleicht auch eine milde aktivistische Seite dazu. Und dann gibt es halt nicht weit weg davon, aber trotzdem was ganz anderes, auch was das Kunstwerk benannt worden ist, das gibt es nicht mehr so richtig, das Ding. Das ist das Macrolab von der slowenischen Künstler Marco Peljan. Das Macrolab ist eigentlich in sich nichts anderes als eine selbstversorgende Medienlabor, die transportabel ist und hat alle Geräte und alle Systeme, in denen man das einfach irgendwo aufbauen kann. Und der versorgt sich selbst von Strom, von Wasser und so weiter und so fort. Und in diesem Lab kommen Künstler als auch Wissenschaftler hin, um Elementen aus unserem unsichtbaren Spektrum zu benutzen, um unter anderem als Kunstwerke zu verorten oder zu produzieren. Das Macrolab ist an verschiedenen Stellen auf die Erde aufgestellt worden. In der Regel in solchen Orten, wo kein Grid gibt, also so weit wie möglich weg von elektromagnetischer Störung und Elektrizität, um mit dem natürlichen Systemen der Erde als elektromagnetischen Objekt zu arbeiten. Es ist ein sehr utopisches Projekt. Es beruht sich auf dem Werk von Vladimir Klebnikov, wo der Zusammenschluss von Kunst und Technologie führt zu einer Art Utopie. Diese Utopie ist natürlich als Utopie unerreichbar und kann nur in Orten wie Antarktis verzogen werden, wo keine Menschen leben. Er hat es geschrieben, damals waren keine Forschungsstationen da. Weil in dem Moment, dass der Mensch mit der Erde in eine Auseinandersetzung setzt, dann bricht gleich diese Utopie. Selbstverherrschende Situation.
Das sind mal ganz schöne Metaprojekte, die du jetzt beschreibst. Hättet ihr jetzt mehr so Installationen und Dinge erwartet, die jetzt mehr auch vielleicht mit den Computern und den Netzwerken arbeiten?
Ja, also Macrolab arbeitet fast mit nichts anderes als Computer und Netzwerke in sich. Aber es ist für mich halt einfach ein sehr wichtiger Kunstwerk in sich. Ich meine, danach und darunter kommen halt einfach vielleicht sehr viele schöne und feine Kunstwerke. Aber die sind sehr schwierig, eins weg von einem anderen zu nehmen. Wenn ich fast random ein Werk aus Transmediale Kontext nehme, eine von den Preisträgen, oder ich weiß nicht, ob es Hauptpreisträge war, von ein paar Jahren, ein Projekt, die hieß Google Will Eat Itself, GWEI. Das war auch eine Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Kunstgruppen über morgan.com, die morgen auch hier in Berlin eine Premiere bei dem Damm-Galerie hat.
Die auch schon zu Gast waren im Übrigen, hier bei Chaosradio Express, da kam das Projekt auch schon zur Sprache.
Okay, und die haben das gemacht zusammen mit zwei italienische Künstler, Alessandro Ludovico und Paolo Cirio. Okay, also eure Zuhörer kennen das Projekt schon. Wenn sie die Folge gehört haben. Wenn die ich die Folge gehört habe.
Die ganz toll war übrigens.
Und das ist auch so ein geniales Projekt, wo es darum ging, über den AdServe-Clicks, im Prinzip, wie nennt man das, Shares, Aktienanteile von Google zu kaufen, sodass durch den Prozess von Google selbst der Nutzer dann Google aufkauft. Und da ist eine Berechnung, das würde bei so und so vielen Clicks 43.000 Jahre oder so was dauern. Aber es ist ja machbar und es war auch ein Projekt, wo Google sehr unglücklich war darüber. Die finden das nicht gut. Und schon sehr interessant, dass die sich bedroht fühlten von so einer Aktion, die vielleicht erst in 43.000 Jahren zu Ende gebracht werden kann. Aber das zeigt auch, wo diese unsichere Unsicherheit mit den Medien und dieser künstlerischen Auseinandersetzung dann aufeinander prallen, dass so eine Riesenwiege wie Google so Angst haben kann von ein paar crazy Artists, die so ein konzeptuelles Werk auf die Beine zu stellen. Und was das denn sagt über das Businessmodell von Google. Und da kommen wir wieder zurück vielleicht zu einen Aspekten von wie Kunst in unsere technologische und digitale Kultur zurückzuführen sind. Also wo da Wege sind, andere Sachen zu sehen. Ich meine, man kann so und so viele Berichte über Google haben, über deren Businessmodell, aber so ein einfacher Kunstwerk hat irgendwie das Thema direkt auf den Punkt in sehr schöne Art und Weise gebracht. Und dieses Jahr gibt es auch vielleicht ein ähnliches Projekt. Das ist vielleicht ein klassischer Kunstprojekt in dem Sinne. Auch von einer Transmediale Award-Nominee, die Christine Lahr aus Leipzig. Sie hat ein Projekt namens Marktgeschenke, das Kapital. Sie überweist jeden Tag 1 Cent an den Bundesfinanzministerium. Und mit dieser Überweisung von dem 1 Euro Cent schreibt sie einen Überweisungsschein aus. Ganz normal. Und auf den Überweisungsschein gibt es, glaube ich, 118 Felder, also für den Verwendungszweck. Und sie überweist mit dem 1 Cent Stück für Stück Marxs, also Karl Marxs, das Kapital. Und indem sie das macht, geht sie ab und zu mal auch zum Finanzministerium und will halt irgendwas erreichen, auch mit dieser Geschenk, die sie an den Staat macht. Und für den Staat, das das Geschenk anerkennt oder nicht, weil es geht sie auch um die Abbau von Schulden und das kapitalistische System natürlich. Und sie setzt sich sozusagen richtig ein und versucht, hinter das Geld her zu rennen. Und bei ihr gibt es auch eine Kalkulation, die ist mehr als etwa 40 Jahre gedauert, das Buch zu überweisen. Und sie wird diese Projekt als Art innovative Performance bei den Transmedialen zeigen. Sie wird jeden Tag sein und sie forscht nach ihrem Geschenk nach.
Wo ist denn jetzt der Medienaspekt bei so einer Arbeit? Das ist für mich schon ein Begriff, Medienkunst, das man einfach nur so einen Begriff hat, der sich so entwickelt hat, der passt mal, mal passt er nicht. Aber hier ist ja sozusagen jetzt das Medium schon im besten Fall noch die Banküberweisung.
Ja, also wenn man das sozusagen so auf diese Technologie in dem Sinne reduziert. Und deswegen meine ich, ich finde es sehr schwierig, diese Begriffe, diese Kunstwerke so in solche Schubladen zu stecken. Was dahinter steht, ist auch eine bestimmte gesellschaftliche und politische Kontext. Und sicherlich hätte man das einfache machen können, das Buch von Marx abzuschicken, wird niemand lesen. Jetzt kommt es häppchenweise rüber und man nutzt eine bestimmte Art von Prozess, die eine Symbolik hat, um etwas zu tun, was letztendlich auch eine technologische Systeme ist, die vor irgendwelchen Jahren auch nicht so in dem Form gab. Ich glaube nicht, dass das unbedingt ihre Leitsin ist, aber sie will schon, dass diese Text auch in eine bestimmte Stelle ankommt. Sie hat sozusagen diese Mittel, diese Struktur gefunden, um das so zu tun.
Das steht irgendwo in der Datenbank. Irgendwo steht es drin.
Ja, es ist da. Und ich meine, das Witz auch mit der ganzen Sache ist, dass natürlich unsere Systeme sind auch da, um all solche Prozesse zu beschleunigen. Also immer schneller, immer kleiner, immer besser. Aber für ihre Systeme, sie braucht halt jeden Tag einen Cent, einen Cent, einen Cent. Aber da ist sie garantiert, dass am Ende des Prozesses dieses Text denn eigentlich da ist. Was nicht passieren würde, wenn man einfach ein PDF von das Kapital als Finanzministerium geschickt wird. Und das ist auch eine, ja, das ist so eine Art System-Hack in dem Sinne. Und damit gehört es schon in der, in dieser so Body of Work sozusagen, die in diesem Kontext von Kunst und digitale Kultur gehört. Das Medienkunst ist, das ist ja immer so der große Frage.
Okay, lass mir das mal offen. Ja, du hast vorhin so nochmal dieses Bild bemüht mit früher war alles anders. Und da haben wir ja noch die Technologie sozusagen Stück für Stück zusammengebaut, um sie zu verstehen. Konkret sehe ich das ja gerade wieder kommen. Also es gibt verschiedene Trends, sei es der Trend zu den Hacker-Spaces, der hier schon eine Rolle gespielt hat. Auch dieses Neue selber machen mit Makerbots. Und ich baue mir sozusagen meinen eigenen 3D-Plotter. Ich baue mir eine Maschine, die mir meine Realität zurecht rendert. Aber auch so grundlegende Projekte wie zum Beispiel das Arduino-Projekt, finde ich, hat eine unglaubliche Auswirkung auf die Kunstszene als solche gehabt. Ich war vor ein paar Wochen in München auf einer relativ neuen kleinen Konferenz, die sich mit dem Aspekt Code auseinandergesetzt hat. Also Code-Visualisierung, also Visualisierung durch Code. Dass man als Programmierer Software schreibt, die dann eben Visualisierung erzeugt. Also weg von diesem traditionellen Ich mal was Schönes oder Ich benutze vielleicht Photoshop. Dann habe ich sozusagen ein digitales Werkzeug, digitale Speicherung. Aber der eigentliche grafische Prozess geht eben immer noch durch meine Hand, selbst wenn sie auf einer Maus liegt, hin zu einem Ich schaffe Algorithmen, ich schaffe Ideen konkret in Software, die dann eben Daten oder Echtzeitereignisse in Bildersprache umsetzen. Dort war dann halt auch einer der Gründer dieses Arduino-Projektes, hat dort berichtet und hat dann auch wiederum von seiner Frühzeit berichtet, wo er Technologie in der Hand hat.
Massimo Banzi?
Genau, der war das, den Namen hatte ich gerade nicht in der Hand. Und er zeigte dann wiederum das Spielzeug, mit dem er früher gearbeitet hat. Und das war, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es heißt, aber es war von Braun, also von Dieter Rams, dem legendären Designer, der im Prinzip ja alles schon mal konzeptionell so weit entworfen und auch umgesetzt hat, womit Apple heute seine Milliarden verdient. Und Dieter Rams hatte auch so einen Elektronik-Baukasten gebaut, aus so einzelnen Modulen, die sich wie Dominosteine aneinander liegen lassen und womit man eben auch funktionierende Schaltungen machen konnte.
Das ist, was ich früher vorhin meinte, mit Transistoren und so weiter.
Genau, aber keine richtigen Transistoren. Also nicht das einzelne Bauteil, wie man es jetzt in einem Gerät finden würde, sondern sozusagen eingebaut in so einen kleinen Baustein, die alle dieselbe Größe hatten, den man eben so aneinander schieben konnte. Und das sehe ich eben jetzt durch solche Sachen wie Arduino, aber auch viele andere Projekte, die in diesem Bereich tummeln, das eben auch so die Hardware und das selber bauen und dieses ich muss es von unten nach oben verstehen, um wirklich mich damit auseinandersetzen zu können. So wie der Künstler ja auch die Gesellschaft im Idealfall von unten nach oben versucht zu verstehen. Dieses Google-Bullet-Eats-Hälfte, da ist ja dieses Verständnis des kapitalistischen Stroms, der Anteilnahme an Kapitalvermögen durch Anteile, durch Shares, durch die Aktien, steckt da ja auch alles mit drin. Und ich denke, das ist dann auch wieder etwas, was den Hackergedanken dann sehr eben mit der Kunst versöhnt, dass hier die Analyse der gesellschaftlichen Ist-Situation vordergrund steht und sich eben durch das Kunstwerk, sei es Software, sei es eine interessant hergestellte Grafik oder ein funktionierendes System bis hin zu so einem Prozess, so einem Hack, sich darin dann eben konkret manifestiert.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und ich meine, das Arduino-Board ist in gewisser Weise so wie so eine Art Pinsel. Man muss auch lernen, wie das am besten funktioniert und was man damit alles machen kann. Und das, was man mit dem Ding machen kann, ist fast alles Mögliche. Das ist auch eine der führenden Kräfte davon. Und Massimo Banzi versteht sich selber nicht als Künstler, aber da sind bestimmt viele Künstler, die ihn als Künstler bezeichnen würden. Man würde auch nicht der Finder der Pinsel unbedingt als Künstler bezeichnen. Der hat ganz andere Hintergründe, warum er das Ding entworfen hat.
Er sieht sich wahrscheinlich eher als jemand, der eine Plattform bereitstellt, ein Betriebssystem.
Genau, und er hat dieses Plattform notwendige, hat das Ding gebaut und dann merkte er, es gibt ja auch Interesse von anderen für solche Sachen. Das ist halt einer der besten Open-Technologies-Beispielen, die es gibt, also das Open-Source-Gedanke, die auch innerhalb der sogenannten Medienkunst oder der Digital-Kultur heute auch sehr wichtig ist. Eigentlich sehe ich die Zukunft der künstlerischen Auseinandersetzung auch sehr viel in diesen Kontext gehen, obwohl das ein Hardware- oder Software-Gedanke ist, weil da gibt es auch die Möglichkeit, die Gestaltung, das Kreativpotenzial, die in jeder einzelnen Mensch steckt, viel breiter zu ziehen als zum Beispiel in geschlossene Systeme wie Photoshop. Man kennt, das ist fast wie CD-ROM-Art wieder, da kennt man die Bilder, die sozusagen auf solche Plattformen gemacht sind, oder solche Software.
Das ist doch geschoppt.
Das ist geschoppt, ja. Aber da gibt es halt, wie Arduino, da gibt es ja auch Processing zum Beispiel. Und wer weiß, wo das denn hingeht. Das ist auch das Schöne daran. Man weiß, dass es von Casey Reyes kommt, die selber auch Künstler ist. Und er hat den Bedürfnis, eine Software zu bauen, die seine Art von Kunst irgendwie zum Leben bringen kann. Und er gibt das sozusagen, den Code an allen anderen, um damit zu benutzen. Und jetzt taugt das überall in allen möglichen Manifestationen aus.
Würdest du denn die Leute, wenn sie sich selber schon nicht als Künstler sehen, würdest du das so sehen? Würdest du sagen, machst du mir Wannsee, also diese Leute, die jetzt diese Plattformen geschaffen haben, dass das Künstler im einigen Sinne sind?
Ich würde niemand unterstellen, Künstler zu sein, die das nicht sind oder wollen. Da muss er selber das schon sagen. Man kann schon sagen, dass er vielleicht künstlerisch arbeitet, manchmal so. Der ist halt einfach ein genialer Designer. Aber da muss er schon selber auf die Idee kommen.
Ich kenne diesen Konflikt. Wir hatten das bei unserem Blinkenleitz-Projekt auch. Das Wort Kunst fiel da nicht, als das entstanden ist. Später wurde das dann auch an uns herumgetragen. Das werden ja wohl welche sein. Und ich werde nie vergessen als dieser britische Reporter. Ja, ich hab mich anrief, weiß gar nicht mehr, für wen er schrieb, und mir irgendwie erzählte, dass gerade in Britannien, wie heißt dieser Kunst, dieser Turner-Preis, gerade an jemanden gegangen ist, der so eine Installation gemacht hat mit einem Raum, wo die ganze Zeit ein Licht an und aus geht. So, ja, und dachte ich mir so, okay, ist klar, wir haben so 144 Räume, wo das Licht an und aus geht. Kriegt der jetzt auch 144 Turner-Preise. Aber der nannte halt auch so, ja, Künstler. Und ich konnte damit gar nichts anfangen, weil ich mir dachte, wie Künstler, wir haben doch hier nur ein System bereit, eine Plattform bereitgestellt, auf die sich Leute ausdrucken können.
Ja, das ist auch eine sehr, sehr ästhetische Projekt. Und das ist da, wo es interessant ist, wenn der Kunstlabel sozusagen auf etwas erzwungen wird. Weil das muss ja ein Kunstwerk sein. Es ist anders, als einfach hier das Ding einen auszuklicken. Weil das wirkt auf ästhetische Basis, auf Leute. Da gibt es eine Interaction mit den Leuten, die da so Bilder damit selber erzeugen können.
Du musst jetzt auch Bilder in den Köpfen der Hörer erzeugen.
Entschuldigung, das We-Gerät. Die We-Mode. Kunstwerke scheitern manchmal, weil der Künstler denkt, etwas Ästhetisches für das Andere gefunden zu haben, die es gar nicht sind. Aber es ist ja trotzdem ein Kunstwerk, wenn er so definiert wird.
Wo bestehen denn jetzt so die? Du hast ja eine beneinswerte Position, wenn man so eine Phase an der Projektleiter schafft, dann auch mal beendet, dann richtet sich wieder der Blick nach vorne. Wenn man das jetzt mal so allgemein für diese Szene, Branche, das trifft alles nicht. Aber sagen wir mal, diesen Kontext Technik, Kunst, Gesellschaft, wenn man denen mal hinstellt, was steht an? Hat das noch Relevanz? Wird es mehr Relevanz bekommen? Müsste es mehr Relevanz bekommen? Ist das sozusagen ein wichtiger Prozess für den Fortschritt der Menschheit? Oder ist das nur so unterferner liefen? Was kannst du Leuten raten, die sich heute schon mit Technologie stark auseinandersetzen und vielleicht in der Lage sind, solche Plattformen zu schaffen für andere Künstler, selbst wenn sie sich selber nicht als solche verstehen? Was geht dir da durch den Kopf?
Ich glaube, dass ist heute sogar wichtiger denn je, diese Auseinandersetzung. Weil gerade, wo die Systeme, mit denen wir täglich zu tun haben, größer und unübersichtlicher werden, ist die Notwendigkeit, selber diese Sachen zu verstehen, gegebenfalls anders zu sehen und anders zu manipulieren und zu benutzen, immer wichtiger. Also wir brauchen halt auch einfach andere Vokabuläre zu lernen, um zu verstehen, was hinter bestimmten Dingen stecken. Und da spielt Kunst auch eine wichtige Rolle, ist nicht das einzige Rolle. Aber der Kunst hat auch die Möglichkeit ab und zu zu überraschen und zu schocken und dann damit auch die Sicht der Dinge anders darzustellen. Und ich glaube schon, dass wir ein bisschen aufpassen müssen, um unsere vielleicht hart erkämpften Freiheiten im Internet zu bewahren. Das kann bestimmt schlagartig ändern. Und da spielen nicht nur, aber auch Künstler auch eine sehr wichtige Rolle da drin. Vielleicht, wenn man das absolut reduziert aus dem kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner, dass dieses Raum auch bewahrt werden muss für einfach offene Kreation und Meinungsfreiheit. Und innerhalb der offenen Meinungsfreiheit muss sie auch die künstlerische Auseinandersetzung geben. Und wenn das Struktur restriktiv ist, oder zensiert wird, oder zu Selbstsensur gepusht wird, dann klappt dieses Raum zu und erlöscht auch die künstlerische und kreative Möglichkeit. Und das schlägt schon auf die Gesellschaft. Ich meine, dass es die einen existiert nicht unbedingt ohne der andere. Und ich sehe das wirklich, dass das heute, also jetzt wirklich, ist fast so eine Art Tipping Point des Internets vielleicht oder des World Wide Web vielleicht. Und deswegen auch, dass die Open Web-Bestrebungen, Projekten, Ideen, die nicht nur von Mozilla, aber auch von vielen anderen gepusht werden, dass sie schon sehr stark nachgehen müssen. Und dass unter anderem, genau wie bei den Künstlern auch, dass zum Beispiel auch den Chaos Computer Club, und das tut sich auch, muss sich öffnen zu der Breite. Also Leute müssen verstehen, warum tun die das und wie tun die das mehr, als es vielleicht bisher angenommen wurde. Es ist nicht nur da, um irgendwie Militärs auszuspielen oder so, sondern da steht auch ganz, ganz wichtige Sachen, die für unsere offene Gesellschaft und zivile gesellschaftliche Strukturen wichtig sind da drin.
Ja, Stephen, ich glaube, damit können wir es auch bewenden lassen, hier bei dem Gespräch, was so ein kleines Experiment war. Ich finde es ein gelungenes Experiment. Einfach mal so ein bisschen auseinander zu dröseln, was so Kunst, Technologie, Gesellschaft im Zusammenhang füreinander bedeuten kann.
Ich danke dir.
Viel Glück mit der nächsten Transmediale, die nächste Woche ansteht. Womit geht es dann weiter für dich?
Steht das schon fest? Unter anderem und unter vielen anderen Dingen ist dieses Jahr das 100. Jahrestag der Geburt von Marshall McLuhan. Da gibt es eine Menge los. Es wird auch hier in Berlin Ende Mai eine große Veranstaltung dazu geben. Für mich persönlich, was mich seit 20 Jahren treibt, ist diese Auseinandersetzung, um offene und freie Strukturen durch Kunst, Medien, Gesellschaft, Technologie zu pushen.
Also du bleibst dem Thema verbunden?
Als Architekt immer. Keine andere Chance.
Gut, das war's. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ich denke, das war ein guter Einstieg hier in das Jahr 2011. Es bleibt wie immer ein buntes Programm. Ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und erhoffe wie immer eure Kommentare und Unterstützung. Ich sage vielen Dank an Stephen.
Ja, ich danke mich auch. Ich werde zurück zu unserem Team.
Genau, das werde ich jetzt auch tun.